the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so we're going on to the third unit here
so we're getting started with unit three
and this is our intro to integration
which is basically the second half of
calculus after differentiation today
what I'll talk about is what are known
as definite integrals well actually it
looks like our are we missing a bunch of
overhead lights it's their reason for
that hmm let's see
ah all right okay that's a little
brighter now alright so the idea of
definite integrals is can be presented
in a number of ways but I will be
consistent with the rest of the
presentation and the in the course we're
going to start with a geometric point of
view and the geometric point of view is
the problem we want to solve is to find
the area under a curve
the other point of view that one can
take and we'll mention that at the end
of this lecture is the idea of
accumulative sum so keep that in mind it
there's a there's a lot going on here
and there are many different
interpretations of what the integral is
now so let's let's draw a picture here
I'll start at a place a and end at a
place B and I have some curve here and
what I have in mind is to find this area
here and of course in order to do that I
need more information than just where we
start and where we end I also need the
bottom and the top by convention the
bottom is the x-axis and the top is this
curve that we've specified which is y
equals f of X and we have a notation for
this which is the notation used in
calculus for this as opposed to some
geometric notation and that's the
following expression it's called an
integral but now it's going to have what
are known as limits on it it'll start at
a and end it B and we write in the
function f of X DX so this is what's
known as a definite integral and it's
interpreted geometrically as the area
under the curve the only difference
between this collection of symbols and
what we had before with indefinite
integrals is that before we didn't
specify where it started and where it
ended
now in order to understand what to do
with this guy I'm going to just describe
very very abstractly what we do and then
carry out one example in detail so to
compute this area we're going to follow
initially three steps first of all we're
going to divide into rectangles and
unfortunately because it's impossible to
divide a curvy region into rectangles
we're going to cheat so there are only
quote-unquote rectangles they're almost
rectangles and the second thing we're
going to do is to add up the areas and
the third thing we're going to do is to
rectify this problem that we didn't
actually hit the answer on the nose that
we were missing some pieces or or
choosing some extra bits and the way
will rectify that is by taking the limit
as the rectangles get thin
infinitesimally thin very thin
pictorially again that looks like this
we have a and our B and we have our guy
here which is our curve and I'm going to
chop it up first I'm going to chop up
the x-axis into little increments and
then I'm going to chop things up here
and I'll decide on some rectangle maybe
some staircase pattern here like this
now I don't care so much in some cases
the rectangles overshoot in some cases
they're underneath so the new area that
I'm adding up is off it's not quite the
same as the area under the curve it's
it's got it's this region here but it
includes these extra bits here and then
it's missing this this little guy here
this little bit there is missing and as
I say these little pieces up here
this little bit up here is extra alright
so that's why they're there we're not
really dividing up the region into
rectangles we're just taking rectangles
and then the the idea is that as these
get thinner and thinner the little itty
bitty amounts that we missed by are
going to zero and they're going to be
negligible already you can see it's kind
of a thin piece of area so we're not
missing by much and as these get thinner
and thinner the problem goes away and we
get the answer on the nose in the limit
all right so here's our first example
I'll take the first interesting curve
which is f of X is equal to x squared I
don't want to do anything more
complicated than one example because
this is a real labor here what we're
going to go through and to make things
easy for myself I'm going to start at a
equals zero but in order to see what the
pattern is I'm going to allow B to be
arbitrary all right
let's draw the graph and start breaking
things up so here's the parabola and
there's this piece that we want which is
going to stop at this place of B here
and the first step is to divide into n
pieces that means well graphically I'll
just mark the first three and maybe
they're going to be many of them and
then I'll draw some rectangles here and
I'm going to choose to make the
rectangles all the way from the right
that is they'll make us this staircase
pattern here like this
that's my choice I get to choose
whatever level I want and I'm going to
choose the right ends as the as the
shape of the staircase so I'm
overshooting with each rectangle and now
I have to write down formulas for what
these areas are now that there's one big
advantage that rectangles have and this
is the starting place which is that
there it's easy to find their areas all
you need to know is the base and the
height and you multiply and get the area
that's the reason why we can get started
with rectangles and in this case these
distances I'm assuming that they're all
equal equally spaced intervals and I'll
always be doing that and so the spacing
the bases the base length is always be
divided by n all equal intervals so
that's the base length and next I need
the heights and in order to keep track
of the heights I'm going to draw a
little table here with with x and f of X
and plug in a few
values just to see what the pattern is
the first place here after zero is B
divided by n so here's B divided by n
that's an x value and the f of X value
is the height there and that's just I
evaluate f of X f of X is x squared and
that's B divided by up and the quantity
squared and similarly the next one is 2
B over N and the value here is to be
over and the quantity squared right
that's this this height here is is to be
divided by n that's the second the
second rectangle and I'll write down one
more 3 B over n that's the third one and
the height is 3 B over n the quantity
squared and so forth
well my next job is to add up these
areas and I've already prepared that by
finding out what the base and the height
is so the total area are the sum of the
areas let's say of these rectangles is
well the first one is B over N times B
over N squared the second one is 2 B
over n I'm sorry is B over N times 2b
over N squared and it just keeps on
going and the last one is B over N times
n B over N squared so it's very
important to figure out what the general
formula is and here we have a base and
here we have a height and here we have
the same kind of base but we have a new
height and and so forth and the pattern
is that the coefficient here is 1 then 2
then 3 all the way up to n the
rectangles are getting taller and taller
and this one the last one is the biggest
okay this is a very complicated gadget
and the first thing I want to do is
simplify it and then I'm actually going
to evaluate it but actually I'm not
going to evaluate it exactly I'm just
going to evaluate the limit
turns out limits are always easier the
point about calculus here is that these
rectangles are hard but the limiting
value is an easy value so what we're
heading for is the simple formula as
opposed to the complicated one all right
so the the first thing I'm going to do
is factor out all these B over N factors
there's a B over N here and there's a B
over N squared so all told we have a B
over N the quantity cubed as a common
factor and then the first term is 1 in a
second term what's left over is 2
squared 2 squared
and then the third term would be 3
squared although I haven't written it
and the last term there's an extra
factor of N squared in the in the
numerator
okay it's everybody with me here now
what I'd like to do is to what I'd like
to do is to eventually take the limit as
n goes to finit infinity here and the
quantity that's hard to understand is
this massive quantity here and there's
one change that I'd like to make but
it's a very modest one extremely
minuscule which is that I'm going to
write one just to see that there's a
general pattern here I'm going to write
1 as 1 squared and well let's put in the
3 here why not and now I want to use a
trick this trick is is is not completely
recommended but I will I will say a lot
more about that when we when we get
through to the end I want to understand
how big this quantity is so I'm going to
use a geometric trick to draw a picture
of this quantity namely I'm going to
build a pyramid and the base of the
pyramid is going to be n by n blocks so
imagine we're in Egypt and we're
building a pyramid and the next layer is
going to be n minus 1 by n minus 1 so
this next layer n is n minus 1 by n
minus 1 so the total number of blocks on
the bottom layer is n squared that's
this this rightmost term here but the
next term which I didn't write in but
maybe I should the Bary the next to the
last term was this one and that's the
second layer that I've put on now this
is the this is if you like the top view
but perhaps we should also think in
terms of a side view so here's the same
picture here's we're starting at N and
we build up this layer here and now
we're going to put a layer on top of it
which is a little shorter so the first
layer is of length N and the second
layer is a length n minus 1 and then on
top of that we have something of length
n minus 2 and so forth and we're going
to pile them up so we pile them up all
the way to the top which is just one one
one giant block of stone and that's this
last one one squared so we're going
backwards in the sum and so I have to
build this whole thing up and I get all
the way up in this staircase pattern to
this top block up there alright so
here's the trick that you can use to
estimate the size of this and it's
sufficient in the limit as n goes to
infinity the trick is that I can imagine
the solid thing underneath the staircase
like this
that's a ordinary pyramid not a not a
not a staircase pyramid which is which
is inside and this one is inside and so
but it's but it's an ordinary pyramid as
opposed to a staircase pyramid and so we
know the formula for the volume of that
because we know the formula for volumes
of cones and the formula for the volume
of this guy of the inside is 1/3 base
times height and in that case the base
here so that's 1/3 and the base is n by
n right so the base is N squared that's
the base and the height it goes all the
way to the top point so the height is in
and what we've discovered here is that
this pulse sum is bigger than one-third
and cubed
now I claim that this line by the way
has slope - so you go half over each
time you go up one that's why you get to
the top on the other hand I can trap it
on the outside - by drawing a parallel
line out here and this will go down a
half more on this side and a half more
on the other side so the base will be n
plus 1 by n plus 1 of this bigger
pyramid and it'll go up one higher
alright so on the other end we get that
this is less than 1/3 n plus 1 cubed
again n plus 1 squared times n plus 1
again this is a base times the height of
this bigger pyramid yes question
the question is it seems as if I'm
adding up areas and equating it to
volume but I'm actually creating volumes
by making these honest increments here
that is the the base is n but the height
is 1 okay the the thank you for pointing
that out
each one of these little staircases here
has exactly height 1 so I'm honestly
sticking blocks there they're sort of
square blocks and I'm lining them up and
I'm getting thinking of N by n cubes if
you like honest cubes there and there
the height is 1 and the base is N
squared okay all right so I claim that
I've trapped this guy in between two
quantities here and now I'm ready to
take the limit
if you look at what our goal is we want
to have an expression like this and I'm
going to this was the massive expression
that we had and actually I'm going to
write it differently I'll write it as B
cubed times 1 squared plus 2 squared
plus plus N squared divided by n cubed
I'm going to combine all the ends
together alright so the right thing to
do is to divide what I had up there
divided by n cubed in this in this set
of inequalities there and what I get
here is 1/3 is less than 1 plus 2
squared plus 3 squared plus n squared
divided by n cubed is less than 1/3
times n plus 1 cubed divided by n cubed
and that's 1/3 times 1 plus 1 over n
cubed and now I claim we're done because
this is 1/3 and the limit as n goes to
infinity of this quantity here is easily
seen to be this is as n goes to infinity
this goes to 0 so this also goes to 1/3
and so our Tolle total here so our total
area under x squared all right which we
sometimes might write the integral from
0 to be x squared DX is going to be
equal to well it's this 1/3 that I've
got but then there was also a B cubed
there so there's this extra B cubed here
so it's 1/3 B cubed that's the that's
the result from this whole computation
yes question
a very good question the question is why
did we leave the B over n cubed out for
this step and part of the answer is
malice aforethought in other words we
know what we're heading for we know we
understand this quantity it's all one
thing this thing is a sum which is
growing larger and larger it's not
what's called a closed form so the thing
that's not known or not well understood
is how big is this quantity here one
squared plus two squared the sum of the
squares whereas this is something that's
quite easy to understand so we factored
it out and we analyzed carefully the the
piece which we we don't know yet how big
it is we discover that it's very very
similar to n cubed but it's more similar
to one-third n cubed it's almost
identical to one-third n cubed that this
extra piece here so that's what's going
on and then we match that since this
thing is very similar to one third and
cubed we cancel the n cubes and we have
our result all right
let me just mention that although this
may seem odd in fact this is what you
always do if you analyze these kinds of
sums you always factor out whatever you
can and then you still are faced with a
sum like this so you will just will
happen systematically every time you're
faced with such a sum okay now I want to
say one more word about notation which
is that this notation is an extreme
nuisance here and it's really sort of
too large for us to deal with and so
mathematicians have a shorthand for it
unfortunately when you actually do a
computation you're going to end up with
with this collection of stuff anyway but
I want to just show you the summation
notation in order to compress it a
little bit the idea of summation
notation is the following so this this
thing tends the idea is the following
I'll illustrate it with an example first
so well the general notation is the sum
of AI I equals 1 to N is a 1 plus a 2
plus plus a n so this is the this is the
abbreviation and this is a capital
signal and so this quantity here for
instance is 1 over N cubed times the sum
I squared I equals 1 to n all right so
that's that's what this thing is equal
to and what we just showed is that that
tends to 1/3 as n goes to infinity all
right so this is the this is the way the
summation notation is is is used there's
a formula for each of these coefficients
each of these entries here or
summons and then this is just an
abbreviation for what the sum is and
this is the reason why I stuck in that
one squared at the beginning so that you
could see that the pattern worked all
the way down to I equals one it isn't an
exception to the to the rule it's the
same as all of the others now over here
in this board we also had one of these
extremely long sums and this one can be
written in the following way and I hope
you agree this is rather hard to scan
but the the one way of writing it is
it's the sum from I equals 1 to N of now
I have to write down the formula for the
general term which is B over N times I B
over N squared so that's a way of
abbreviating this massive formula into 1
which is just a lot shorter and now the
manipulation that I performed with it
which is to factor out this B over N
cubed is something that I'm perfectly
well allowed to do also over here this
is the distributive law this if i factor
out b cubed over n cubed I'm left with
the sum I equals 1 to N of I squared all
right so these notations make it a
little bit more compact the what we're
dealing with the conceptual phenomenon
is still the same and the mess is really
still just hiding under the rug but the
notation is at least fits on a few with
a few fewer symbols anyway
all right so let's let's continue here
I've given you one calculation and now I
want to fit it into a pattern and here's
the here's the the thing that I'd like
to calculate so first of all let's try
the case so I'm going to do two more
examples I'll do two more examples but
they're going to be much much easier and
then things are going to get much easier
from now on so the second example is
going to be the function f of X is equal
to X if I draw that that's this function
here that's the line with slope 1 and
here's B and so this area here is the
same as the area of the triangle with
with base B and height B so the area is
equal to 1/2 B times B so this is the
base and this is the height we also know
how to find the area of triangles and so
the formula is 1/2 B squared and the
third example notice by the way I didn't
have to do this elaborate summing to do
that because we happen to know this area
the third example is going to be even
easier f of X is equal to 1 by far the
most important example remarkably when
you get to 1802 in multivariable
calculus you will forget this
calculation somehow and I don't know why
but it's happens to everybody so so the
function is just horizontal like this
right it's the constant one and if we
stop it at B then the area we're
interested in is just this from zero to
B
and we know that this is height one so
this is area base which is B times one
so it's B let's look now at the pattern
we're going to look at the pattern of
the function and it's the area under the
curve which is this as as this elaborate
formula in terms of so this is just the
area under the curve between zero and B
and we have x squared which turned out
to be b cubed over 3 and we have X which
turned out to be well let me write them
over just a bit more to give myself some
room X which turns out to be B squared
over 2 and then we have 1 which turned
out to be B so this I claim is
suggestive if you can figure out the
pattern one way of making it a little
clearer is to see that X is X to the
first power and one is X to the zero
power so this is the case 0 1 and 2 and
B is B to the 1 divided by 1
so if you want to guess what happens
when f of X is X cubed well if it's 0
you do B to the 1 over 1 if it's 1 you
do B to the 2 over 2 if it's 2 you do B
to the 3 over 3 so it's reasonable to
guess that this should be B to the 4
divided by 4 right that's that's a
reasonable guess I would say right now
the strange thing is that in history
Archimedes figured out the area under a
parabola so that was a long time ago it
was after the pyramids and he used
actually a much more complicated method
than I just described here and his
method which is just fantastically
amazing was so brilliant that it may
have set back mathematics by 2,000 years
because people were so it was so
difficult that people couldn't see this
pattern and couldn't see that actually
these kinds of calculations are easy so
they couldn't get to the cubic and even
when they got to the cubic they were
struggling with everything else and it
wasn't until calculus fit everything
together that people were able to make
serious progress on calculating these
areas even though he was the expert on
calculating areas and volumes for his
time so this is really a great thing
that we now can have easy methods of
doing it and the main thing that I want
to tell you is that we will not have to
labor to build pyramids to calculate all
of these quantities we will have a way
faster way of doing it this is the slow
laborious way and we will be able to do
it so easily that it will happen as fast
as you differentiate so that's coming up
tomorrow but I want you to know that
it's going to be however we're going to
go through just a little pain before we
do it
and I'll just tell you one more one more
piece of notation here all right so you
need to have a little practice just to
recognize how how much savings we're
going to make but never again will you
have to face elaborate geometric
arguments like this so let me just add a
little bit of notation for the for for
definite integrals all right and this
goes under the name of Riemann sums
named after a mathematician from the
1800s so this is the general procedure
procedure for definite integrals we
divide it up into pieces and how do we
how do we do that well so here's our a
and here's our here's our B and what
we're going to do is break it up into
little pieces and we're going to give a
name to the increment and we're going to
call that Delta X so we divide up into
these so how many pieces are there if
there are n pieces then the general
formula is always that Delta X is 1 over
N times the total length so it has to be
B minus a over N we will always use
these equal increments although you
don't absolutely have to do it we will
for these Riemann sums
and now there's only one bit of
flexibility in that we will allow
ourselves which is this we're going to
pick any height of F between ends in the
interval in each interval so what that
means is let me just show it to you on
the on the picture here is I just pick
any value in between I'll call it CI
which is in there and then I go up here
and I have the level which is f of CI
and that's the rectangle that I choose
in other in the case that we did we
always chose the right hand a large
which turned out to be the largest one
but I could have stuck chosen some level
in between or even the left hand end
which would have meant that the
staircase would have been quite a bit
lower alright so any of these staircases
will work perfectly well so that means
we're picking F of CI and that's a
height and now we're just going to add
them all up and this is the sum of the
areas of the rectangles because this is
the height and this is the base this
notation is supposed to be now very
suggestive of the notation that that
Leibniz used which is that in the limit
this becomes an integral from A to B of
f of X DX and notice that the Delta X
gets replaced by a DX so this is what
happens in the limit as the the
rectangles get thin so that's as Delta
goes to zero and these these gadgets are
called Riemann sums this is called a
Riemann sum and we already worked out an
example this very complicated guy was an
example of a Riemann sum all right so
that's a notation and will give you a
chance to get used to it a little more
when we do some numerical work at the
end all right now the last thing for
today is I promised you an example which
was not an area example I want to be
able to show you that integrals are can
be interpreted as cumulative sums
integrals as cumulative sums so this is
just an example and and so here's the
here's the way it goes so we're going to
consider a function f we're going to
we're going to consider a variable T
which is time in years and we'll
consider a function f of T which is in
dollars per year all right this is a
financial example here that's the unit
here dollars per year and this is going
to be a borrowing rate
now the reason why I want to put units
in here is to show you that there's a
good reason for this strange DX which we
append on these these integrals this
notation it allows us to change
variables allows us to be consistent
with units and allows us to develop
meaningful formulas which are which are
consistent across the board and so I
want to emphasize the units in this and
it's when I when I set up this modeling
problem here now you're borrowing money
let's say everyday all right so that
means delta T is 1 over 365 that's
almost 1 over infinity from the point of
view of various purposes all right so
this is how much you're borrowing now
each time increment you're borrowing and
let's say that you borrow your rate
varies over the year I mean sometimes
you need more money sometimes you need
less certainly any business would be
that way and so here you are you've got
your money and you're borrowing it but
the rate is varying and so how much did
you borrow well in day 45 which
corresponds to T over 40 is 45 over 365
you borrowed the following amount here
was your borrowing rate times this
quantity so dollars per year and so this
is if you like so I want to emphasize
the scaling that comes about here you
have you have dollars per year and this
is this is this number of years so that
comes out to be in dollars this final
amount this is the amount that you
actually borrow so
borrow this amount and now if I want to
add up how much you get you've borrowed
in the entire year
that's this sum I equals one to 365 of f
of well it's I over 365 times this delta
T which I'll just leave as delta T here
this is total amount borrowed this is
kind of a messy sum in fact your bank
probably will keep track of it and they
know how to do that but when we're
modeling things with strategies you know
trading strategies of course you're
really some kind of financial engineer
and you want to cleverly optimize how
much you borrow and how much you spend
and how much you invest this is going to
be very very similar to the integral
from 0 to 1 of F of T DT at the scale of
1 over 35 tits it's probably go to 365
it's probably enough for many purposes
now however there's there's another
thing that you would want to model which
is equally important this is how much
you borrowed but there's also how much
you owe the bank at the end of the year
and the amount that you owe the bank at
the end of the year I'm going to do it
in a fancy way it's you the interest
will say is compounded continuously so
the interest rate if you start out with
P as your principal then after time T
you owe so borrow P after time T you owe
P times e to the RT where R as your
interest rate say 0.05 per year okay
that would be an example of a of an
interest rate
and so if you want to understand how
much money you actually owe at the end
of the year at the end of the year what
you owe is well you borrowed these
amounts here but now you owe more at the
end of the year you owe
e to the power R times the amount of
time left in the year so the amount of
time left in the year is one minus I
over 365 or 365 minus I days left so
this is 1 minus I over 365 and this is
what you have to add up to see how much
you owe and that is essentially the
integral from 0 to 1 the delta T comes
out and you have here e to the R times 1
minus T so the T is replacing this I
over 365 f of T DT and so when you when
you start computing and thinking about
what's the right strategy you you're
faced with integrals of this type all
right
so that's just an example and see you
next time remember to think about
questions that you'll ask next time